[Music]
hi
my name is chelsea parlette pelarity and
i'm on twitter
at chelsea parlette in case you want to
follow any of the fun stats content that
i make
and speaking of stats content something
that i've spent a lot of time making in
the past year
are guided simulation exercises i teach
data science to
mostly undergraduates and it can be an
intimidating subject to them
i often get asked for rules of thumb
that they can use to make good data
science decisions
and while there are some rules of thumb
that work in a lot of situations
i want my students to come away with a
deep understanding of the concepts
so that when they're in a situation
where that rule of thumb doesn't apply
they're not just stuck i decided that
guided simulation exercises were a great
way to create that deeper
understanding by my definition guided
simulation exercises
are activities where you're asked to
simulate data
you apply an algorithm or a computation
to that data and then you're given
specific guided questions that can help
you figure out what that simulation can
tell you
about whichever algorithm or computation
you apply
to the data simulation exercises are
helpful for three main reasons
first i think it encourages this
attitude of exploration when learning
and second it gives you tools to test
your intuition or
try weird edge cases that you think of
and see what happens
and finally i think it empowers this
deep understanding of the concepts that
you're learning
a lot of people learn data science
because they think they should
but my goal is to help people really
deeply explore the concepts that they're
learning
and sure they could write their own
simulations
but i think the guided part is really
important
i think these exercises are a little
more practical than just
throwing people in the deep end on their
own
it makes simulating data and r
feel more approachable and it gives
people
tools to try and figure things out
themselves rather than just relying on
what they're told
relatedly the guided nature of these
exercises
gives people the tools to learn and try
things on their own
and tailor their experience to things
that specifically make them curious
for example maybe you're wondering what
would happen if i ran principal
component analysis
on a set of variables that are
completely uncorrelated
we'll try it out or maybe you're
wondering
why we would ever use k-fold
cross-validation
rather than the simpler more
computationally efficient train test
split
we'll run a bunch of simulations and see
what the difference is
in my opinion the best data scientists
are the ones who have a little bit of
doubt
about whether the established method is
the best way necessarily
and these guided simulation exercises
encourage
people to test things out to
push on the boundaries of established
methods and to
figure out how our favorite algorithms
work in atypical situations
after all our data will not always be
well behaved
guided simulation exercises are not a
replacement for the math and theory that
go behind data science topics
but it can help support them and i think
that the
examples the specific questions and the
established code
help make simulation more accessible
especially to people who
don't have the skills yet or maybe don't
have the time
to set all of it up on their own i hope
you'll check out the guided simulations
that are already on the conference
github and
all of the ones that we make in the
future but for now in my last minute i
would love to give you the world's
quickest overview of my principal
component analysis
guided simulation exercise when i teach
principal component analysis
one of the main ideas that i emphasize
is that principal component analysis
takes advantage of relationships between
variables
in order to create more efficient axes
that
better define the variation in the data
so it shouldn't be a surprise that when
we look at
principal component analysis on
completely uncorrelated variables
the screenplot shows us that each
variable pretty much contributes its own
independent information
on the other hand when we have highly
correlated variables
the pca model as well as the scree plot
tell us that a lot of the variation than
can be explained by
one single component because there was a
lot of shared information
in the data originally thank you so much
for listening to my talk i would love to
connect with all of you over the
internet and hear whether you use any of
these guided simulation exercises
either for yourself or for people that
you teach
and definitely let me know if you create
any of your own
i would love to hear about it thank you
you